if you're in a final destination movie
your best hope of surviving is to look
for the signs right from the opening
credits there are signs of impending
danger like the scissors pointed at
kimberly's head in this photo or
the blade directed at her face right
next to that kimberly has an eye on her
keychain a clue that she will be the
clairvoyant whose vision saves the lives
of several people
and when she first wakes up that
afternoon the time is 108. an anagram of
180
referencing the flight number of the big
accident from the first movie there
would be many other appearances of the
ominous number 180 as well as many other
signs that often go unnoticed to hear
about every last secret
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by
hunterkiller
welcome to things you missed and if
you're watching on upload day happy
halloween this year's halloween may not
be what we're used to but hopefully you
found a way to enjoy it final
destination 2 brought in a new director
james wong handed it over to david r
ellis who is mostly known for his work
in the stunt department so the result
was
one really cool spectacle at the
beginning of the movie but a lot of
weird stuff for the rest of the film man
with hooks
i think i see a man with hooks we'll get
into that but first let's get into the
things you missed
you missed that
[Music]
kimberly first wakes up at the beginning
of the movie when she hears a strange
voice utter her name
i believe this is the voice of the
coroner william bloodworth who later
somehow knows her name when clear brings
her to the morgue to ask questions about
death suggesting that william could be
much more than a creepy dude who knows a
lot about death
this is effectively the first sign that
she actually notices about the tragedy
that would become known as the route's
23 pileup
the next is when her door suddenly
closes in the past we've seen that death
is often associated with the wind her
and her friends are headed off to a road
trip
to daytona beach a parallel to the first
movie where flight 180 is also a travel
related accident when she drives away
her car is leaking transmission fluid
that almost looks like blood
in our flight 180 analogy the equivalent
of the airport terminal would be the
highway on-ramp and just as alex is
disturbed by a creepy missionary
kimberly is startled by a creepy old
woman collecting trash which her friend
dano finds way funnier than it actually
is
okay they get on the highway and see a
school bus transporting a sports team
there's a banner that says demolish the
mustangs smoke their butts
and later down the road they would
encounter a ford mustang with smoke
coming out of the butt and it gets
demolished in the accident
we see the bus for realsies after the
premonition and learned that it's a bus
from mount abraham high school which is
the school whose french class fatally
boarded flight 180.
alex browning encountered a couple
references to hell and demons before
boarding that plane and when kimberly
changes the radio station
ac dc's highway to hell starts playing
which coincidentally i used to sing
every day in sixth grade on my way to
english class
dino tosses his illegal substance joint
out the window and it lands on the
windshield of a woman named cat where it
burns some leaves that are stuck there
this could either be a sign of the fiery
explosions caused by the pileup or
any of the other four fiery explosions
in this film the real scariest part of
this movie is just the fact that like 50
of the people on this road are driving
under the influence i mean between cat
rory and this truck driver it's a wonder
that it took five whole minutes for a
major accident to occur
by the way the drinking driver
represents a company called heist pill
a reference to stunt coordinator freddie
heist you probably didn't miss the weird
kid smashing together the toy cars
i mean who does that but what you may
not have noticed is that it's a red
truck
crashing into a big blue commercial
vehicle which is not only what happens
at the end of kimberly's vision but also
what happens for real when kimberly
loses her friends after stepping out of
her vehicle the truck that starts the
big pile up in kimberly's vision has a
loose wire hanging off the back of it
which brings back memories of the end of
the first movie where a similar wire
almost caused the death of the main
characters clear in alex this truck also
has a familiar license plate vky
722 we last saw this plate in my things
you missed episode on stephen king's
misery where it was the license plate of
paul sheldon's car and i mentioned that
it's appeared in many movies like the
freshman
shaft and the wolf of wall street
finally after the premonition when the
real accident occurs kimberly looks up
and sees a sign that says warning
worked ahead connects 180 feet this is
the number 180 resurfacing as it has so
many times
since flight 180 as i discussed when i
covered the first movie the new number
added to the mix this time is the number
23.
kimberly notices that the next service
station is 23 miles away
after her dad calls her to warn her
about her car's leak final destination 2
is pretty much the same exact movie as
the first with one key difference
this time william bloodworth tells them
that the only way to defeat to death is
with new life and so the majority of
this film is spent
trying to make sure nothing bad happens
to this woman isabella so she can safely
deliver her baby and theoretically force
death to completely reset its list
there's a scene later on where we
learned that each character is connected
by the fact that they should have died
at some point over the last year but
each of them missed their appointment
with death because of one of the flight
180 survivors
at the end isabella is revealed not to
have been on death's list yet but that
doesn't mean she isn't connected to the
others we first see her in the
premonition driving her white van which
has a logo for a fresh and fast florist
in other words she's delivering flowers
and i think the reason she's there
is because she's delivering to the
one-year anniversary memorial at mount
abraham high school that we hear about
on the radio
a candlelight vigil to mark the one-year
anniversary of the crash of flight 180
will be held at 8pm tonight at the mount
abraham high school auditorium
after the premonition there's even a
part where she asks to get through
because she has to make a delivery
excuse me is there any way that we could
drive around
i have a delivery you need to get back
into your vehicles i think that fate had
her making this delivery
because death wanted clear to be lured
out of hiding and needed her to end up
at the lakeview hospital when eugene's
room exploded it's all part of death's
design but there would be many more
accidents before then each with their
own clues to uncover
[Music]
the holiday we've been waiting for all
year has finally arrived and if you're
like me you found something scary to
enjoy at home this year because of
covid19
and if you're like me you're looking to
keep things scary all year round
something that i've been enjoying to
fill that halloween void is hunt a
killer's blair witch game
it's basically a subscription box that
puts you in the center of a new horror
mystery taking place in the universe of
one of the greatest found footage movies
of all time the blair witch project each
season consists of six episodes
when you open the box you'll receive
your case file which consists of
realistic evidence we're talking
journals police reports maps and other
documents that'll help you solve the
mystery of black hills forest if i could
compare it to anything i'd say it really
has the feeling of an escape room it's
very hands-on and makes you a character
in the story there are certain parts
where you make a revelation and it's
just genuinely creepy and unsettling
right now for things you missed viewers
you can go to huntykiller.com and use
code cz's world for 20 off your first
box
again make sure to use code cz's world
for a 20 discount and to show your
support for the show
can you survive the curse of the blair
witch
there's a running theme of luck and
chance in final destination 2.
the dice hanging from rory's mirror
represent chan's the police chief
considers each of the survivors to be
very lucky especially evan lewis who won
the lottery the previous day
before getting crushed by a falling
ladder walking under a ladder is
considered bad luck and so
are black cats during evan's incident he
tries cooking lunch for himself using
black cat cooking oil
and evan's new ring is a horseshoe ring
which is considered to be a lucky charm
also that's the only reason that the
colts won the super bowl in 2007
the number 13 is considered to be the
unlucky number and it can be seen on
eugene's billiard ball keychain this
ball starts a chain reaction that nearly
gets someone killed
when we first see this ball in his
keychain eugene is also the 13th
accident survivor on death's list
officer burke is a policeman who is part
of unit 13.
this is unit 13 requesting medical
assistance let's go
practice medicine the first individual
accident scene in the movie is mr lucky
himself evan lewis we see him after he's
used some of his lotto money to buy
expensive stuff
in the hallway outside of his apartments
there are a number of signs a pileup of
toy cars and vehicles that was probably
his first sign about the incident on
route 23. he nearly steps on a toy
ambulance that says mount pleasant on
the side
which is identical to the ambulance that
picks him up after his accident
he nearly falls after stepping on this
one-eyed baby doll which isn't a toy
story reference it's an omen about
evan's eventual fates where the fire
escape ladder punctures his right eye
there's another clue about that in his
kitchen where the refrigerator magnets
seem to spell out hey but the h falls
away think of a ladder as a bunch of h's
stacked on top of one another and the
result is the word i
which is what gets poked out when that
ladder falls and the new computer he
buys is an imac not a nose mac not a
chinmack
an eye malik the song he puts on is
called vitamin by the band incubus who
are named after the latin derived word
which refers to a male demon
another one of the demonic references i
mentioned earlier it goes along well
with his demon tail necklace he also has
this monkey demon statue sitting by his
window which is next to a miniature
version of his 1979 pontiac firebird
trans am which you may remember had a
phoenix decal on its hood
he also has the firebird image on his
front door these are all signs that he's
going to start a fire in his apartment
which ultimately leads him to his death
the mozzarella sticks he cooks are from
a company called surefire snacks which
sure enough
is the catalyst of that apartment fire i
would also say that this incubus song is
fire but
they wouldn't have called it that back
then so i'll just not gonna count that
one i'm just surprised they didn't use
pardon me
a decade ago i never thought i would be
a 23 on the verge of spontaneous
combustion
after evan's over the top ending to
depth perception officer burke looks up
some more info on flight 180 and comes
across a website about plane crash
survivors which has photos of each of
the survivors and for some reason the
photo of todd is captioned as
a nice shot before the coroner arrived
what's nice about that it's a dead 17
year old
also i noticed that their high school
photos are almost definitely taken from
the photo shoot for the final
destination one poster and just given a
different background
various characters learned the news of
evan's death including cats who was
smoking on the treadmill i mean what's
the point of that it would be like if i
made a video and didn't upload it but
there is an interesting painting near
eugene's tv
of what seems to be a person with their
legs severed from the rest of their body
it hints about rory who later gets his
legs cut off by the wire fans
the child tim is reading stephen king's
bag of bones before bed which is a novel
about a writer who has disturbing dreams
and visions much like kimberly does in
this movie speaking of kimberly she has
a few
interesting items of her own that i
haven't mentioned yet because they're
connections to things
outside of this movie for example one of
the first things we see in her room is a
puppet which i think was a reference to
a cut line from mr bloodworth that can
only be seen in the deleted scenes
but be warned to disrupt the grand
design
is to unravel the tapestry of the
universe
and when you pull those threads apart
you might find yourself
hanging from them
[Music]
i also noticed a picture of a bridge in
her room which of course makes me think
about the opening disaster in final
destination 5
even if it wasn't an intentional
reference at the time there's also a
clown and a trapeze in her room makes me
think of another scene from the fifth
one
there's another link to a later movie in
the franchise when nora takes her son to
the dentist's office and a fish gets
stuck in the filter we see a very
similar accident happen
in the fourth movie before that happens
though kimberly goes to talk to the only
remaining flight 180 survivor clear
there's a lot more info here about what
happened to clear in between final
destination 1 and final destination 2 so
i did a whole video on it which you can
check out right here if you're
interested
there are also some names written on the
side here the first three are flight 180
victims who if you've seen my episode on
the first movie you know are named after
crew members the other two names aren't
credits but they appear to be other
hollywood connections for example this
guy worked on the butterfly effect which
is written by the same guy who did final
destination 2. so i think these could
have been other flight 180 victims whose
names were just off screen here
one headline that caught my attention
was this one hollywood jumps on flight
180 bandwagon so does that mean that the
movie final destination also
exists within the universe of final
destination is that what they're saying
here
after talking to clear and seeing some
birds in a window reflection kimberly
makes this conclusion
if clear's right about the order then uh
nora and tim
are gonna be attacked by pigeons okay
that's uh that's a pretty big jump to
make but whatever but that leads us to
the next disaster scene which starts
when we see a skull in the fish tank
the first clue that somebody is gonna
die here the next clue cannot be seen
but only heard
the music playing in the waiting room is
a midi cover of john denver's rocky
mountain high
the song that showed up over and over
before the disaster in the first movie
i'm gonna crank up the volume and roll
it
um the doctor is ready for you now
in the dentist office there are tanks of
nitrous oxide and oxygen used for
laughing gas
this could be seen as a foreshadowing of
the explosive oxygen tanks that kill
clear and eugene at the end of the movie
the way tim dies really doesn't make any
sense to me like he sees it but he
doesn't try to move
no one would have that reaction if they
see something falling on them but tim's
death as ridiculous as it may seem is
nowhere near as outlandish as his
mother's
death would arrive for her not long
after
here are a couple more things i love
about hunter killer's blair witch box
the lore this isn't just a generic game
of clue with a blur witch logo slapped
on it they've actually partnered with
the studio lionsgate to make something
that fits into the blurwitch universe
everything they send you feels like it
belongs in a blurwitch movie so
everything feels very immersive
if you love things you missed you'll
love looking out for those little clues
it's a great feeling whenever you unlock
a new discovery the flexibility there
are so many different ways you can play
i mean i had a fun time just playing by
myself
but there are so many clues and
materials you could easily team up with
a partner a roommate or even get a small
group together
for a little teamthink sesh over video
chat unlike most args you're not just
staring at a screen the whole time so
it's kind of perfect for someone like me
who has a job where
you're just staring at a screen for 16
hours a day
you're going to be getting a 20 discount
using my link which you can find in the
description that's huntykiller.comworld
and use code cz's world for 20
off
in my previous episode i mentioned how a
lot of final destination characters are
named after great classic horror
filmmakers and final destination 2
is no exception kimberly corman and her
dad mr corman are named after roger
corman evan lewis is named after
herschel gordon lewis and
nora and tim carpenter are named after
john carpenter tim's dentist
is named dr liz which could be in honor
of christopher lee one of the most
iconic actors to play dracula
and on burke's computer screen you can
spot an incident report on barker avenue
possibly a nod
to clive barker after the construction
crew discovers that little timmy isn't a
load-bearing wall
clear joins back up with kimberly and
burke to take them to william bloodworth
and try to get some answers wait look at
this
is bloodworth an apostasy fan
good for him i always thought he was
kind of metal clear's alertness prevents
a possible explosion at the gas station
afterwards which would only be a
temporary dodge because as i mentioned
she does end up dying by explosion
actually kind of a lot of people do in
this movie it is there that they figure
out mr bloodworth's cryptic clue
a brand new soul that was never part of
death's design if there's the whole list
out of whack and we start over with a
clean slate seems like a bit of a reach
don't you think
yes thank you this is where the movie
completely turns into
i mean basically a joke they already
tried the whole pregnancy thing where
new life that was never meant to be can
force death to start over in the first
movie they were gonna have clear get
pregnant and then have alex's baby but
then they showed it at test screenings
and it didn't go over well
the whole baby thing they didn't like it
was part of what alex and claire didn't
work and they didn't buy the baby at the
end they thought it was goofy and wasn't
satisfying enough
so why in the [ __ ] did they decide to
try it again
in the second movie it makes no sense so
they look back at burke's cop car cam to
try to find out who isabella is and it
just kind of shows you how sloppy the
movie is
according to the camera it's 9 12 am
when they're on the ramp but when it
happened the first time
it was about 8 16 am and then when we
see it again in the premonition it's 8
24 am
and it gets much worse at the meeting
that burke hosts for the route 23
survivors because rory just completely
forgets about personal boundaries on the
elevator
is that dog dude
oh you got something on there bro here i
can get it for you
no that's it it's all right
just let i'll let me do it
very weird but also did you notice the
elevator
music it's a little hard to tell but
there's an elevator music version of
rocky mountain high i'm gonna play back
that exact part
just let i'll let me do it so they have
the meeting and eugene is just denying
the whole death curse thing i honestly
don't even know why he came to the
meeting because he just mocks them the
entire time and then
he leaves clear explains that they need
to be looking for signs and the rest of
them try to safe proof the apartment
like alex did declares cabin in the
first movie
nora and eugene get into the elevator
with this weird guy and to this day i
still don't understand why he's holding
the stuff
like what it even is are we supposed to
understand what's going on here even
[Music]
man with hooks
ma'am with hooks i think i see a man
with hooks
what do you think they're gonna say oh
my god he's right oh my god
he's right no come on i was kidding
oh oh i'm sorry was it not already weird
enough that this guy who we've never
seen before
is holding a bunch of limbs with hooks
on them just pause it right there
so they try calling nora to warn her
about the man with hooks so let's break
down this phone call
hello nora who is this okay so this
establishes that she doesn't know who's
calling rather than just saying
it's officer burke he just starts
screaming no can you hear me even though
she's given no indication that she's
having trouble hearing up to this point
uh officer burke i can't i
i can't hear you what well if she can't
hear him then how does she now know
who's calling and he still hasn't said
who's calling
a man with hooks is gonna kill you so
she just drops the phone
not asking what that means not asking
for more details not asking for
elaboration
and then she immediately dies
there's more like eugene running
upstairs and suddenly having a meltdown
where he tries to shoot himself but all
the bullets are dud
supposedly because it's not his turn to
die so are we just supposed to believe
that he's invincible until the others
die i mean that makes no sense
because if that's the case just keep
cats in the padded room and send eugene
out to do the rest of the tats if they
do that then they've essentially won but
yeah it seems like they do have to die
in order because later on there's this
part where death knocks down this tree
branch to move burke out of the way so
that he doesn't get killed by the flying
fence that kills rory
so with that in mind the plan that makes
the least sense is sending them all in
the car together with cats who is next
on the list as the driver so naturally
that's exactly what they do so at this
point i'm just gonna take a break i'm
gonna calm down and then uh we can
hopefully get through the rest of this
movie and the rest of the things you
missed
[Music]
[Applause]
in the episode on the first final
destination i pointed out how all of the
disasters manufactured by death were
somehow related to water or liquid and
that trend continues for most of the
accidents in final destination too
in the opening disaster the route 23
pileup we can see that the ground is wet
and water is spraying off of everyone's
tires
obviously that prevented the cars from
breaking when they should have which
helps make the disaster worse but
perhaps even more dangerous than that is
what goes on in nora and tim's car when
we first see them tim is drumming on the
glove compartment with a couple of water
bottles and when the pile up occurs one
of them falls under nora's brake pedal
so she's unable to stop her car from
smashing into what's ahead of them
evan's fatal scene doesn't really have
any water but i will note that things
start going really bad for him when he
gets his hand stuck in the garbage
disposal and is saying
tim's accident occurs at the dentist
starting with when the fish tank springs
a leak out onto the electrical outlet
nora's death doesn't really involve
water at all but it's shown to be
raining during that scene
cat's death is not a result of water
she's killed when her airbag pushes her
into a sharp object but rory's death is
the result of a punctured fuel tank that
drips into a storm drain
eventually causing a news van to explode
and launch a barbed wire fence at him
then there's kimberly who has this plan
at the end that she's gonna die and then
be resuscitated and she does this by
driving an ambulance into the lake
the two that i haven't mentioned yet are
eugene and clear who both die in an
explosion that has nothing to do with
water but you have to consider the
reason that they're there in the first
place
is because isabella the pregnant woman
has her water break seems like a bit of
a reach don't you think
maybe burke maybe but that water break
scene just has some of the best acting
that i've ever seen in a movie
my water it just broke i'm gonna have my
baby no not here no
you can't do this to me don't just stand
there get me to
just give me a second to think um wow
just incredible incredible performance i
mean how did this not win best
supporting actor and actress so
realistic
so captivating incredible job okay i
don't want to just spend this whole
episode just ragging out a movie
i do really like the concept how all of
the route 23 people had their lives
extended because the flight 180
survivors lived longer than they were
supposed to
i just don't get this part wait
wait wait who are these people people
got off of flight 180.
they were my friends hold up
hold on a second let's uh rewind to the
first movie because i certainly do not
remember them being your friends clear
nobody forced you off the plane you said
you weren't friends with those that were
so clear why did you get off the plane
because i saw and i heard alex
like i get that she became friends with
alex and carter at the end of the movie
but she can't act like she was friends
with all of them and by the way what is
this picture placed in her little padded
room this never happened
they were literally fighting with terry
and carter the moment before terry died
there is no point where this picture
could possibly exist why are you trying
to rewrite the history of the first one
i don't want to be too negative i mean
there are actually some good scenes in
this movie
and if i die um
did you throw down my drugs and my
paraphernalia my
porno anything that's gonna break my
mom's heart
you know that's actually like a really
heartfelt moment i mean that makes me
want to roots for this guy to survive
and get his life together but
unfortunately he's dead one minute and
34 seconds later
not long after we find out that the
entire objective of this movie was a lie
because isabella was never supposed to
die in the pileup in the first place and
kimberly has another vision and sees a
new sign in an article that says new
life for drowning victim
if you read the article it seems to be
about another final destination like
event where these two guys just happened
to be at the right place at the right
time to save this woman who had nearly
drowned one of them is quoted in the
article
i wanted to stop at the corn dog shop
which is on the other side of the
hospital
but paul said in no way we're going to
dumpies in two years we've never gone to
dumpies i don't know how to account for
why we suddenly changed our plans it
sounds like maybe one of them had a
vision or saw a sign that influenced
their behavior just like every final
destination opening
and in true final destination fashion
these two guys are named after the crew
members of the movie
so as i mentioned kimberly drives into a
lake and is brought back by the
paramedics
ready clear no no you got it all wrong
clear's the dead one this is kimberly
the final scene is this dinner scene
with the family of the farmer whose land
they crashed on when their tires blew
out so they run a car into this dude's
farm
cause all kinds of havoc and trouble
nearly get his son run over by a news
van and he responds by
trusting them with his truck when they
just met and inviting them over for
dinner in any event way back towards the
beginning of this video i mentioned all
of the references to luck
chance and misfortune and when the
farmer's wife learns of how her son
narrowly avoided getting hit by a van
thanks to rory's intervention she speaks
the final line of the movie
boy that was lucky
click the video on the left for the next
episode of final destination things you
missed and if you love horror remember
to subscribe
to cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive and if you want
to beat death use a face mask and social
distancing
you